the way people talk about the future has
changed when we were kids the future was
a very positive thing we were going to
solve all these problems and have
jetpacks and everything everybody seems
to have abandoned that view of the
future and we wondered why why is that
change the future is running out this
film in its own popcorn II righty way
touches on that theme the themes are
really about empowering people to make a
change I am a huge fan of imax theaters
are designed in a way to make you sit
closer and fill your field of view not
only are the screens huge but you're
forced to kind of sit a little more in
it and that changes the way you look at
it to me it's keeping the immersive film
experience alive that's why I love to
see things in imax it really is about an
entire experience it's not just the
visual it'll come to life even more you
know it's sounds it's feeling like
you're there
the reason to see a movie has not really
changed in a hundred years hang on
from the beginning movies have demanded
to be big
and the best way to see a film is on a
giant screen with a lot of other people
it's a communal ride one of the best
ways to experience that feeling today is
in imax that's a great way to see
tomorrow
you